foreign
there are more and more kids trying
drugs because drugs are basically legal
now marijuana is legal so anyone can
anyone can smoke marijuana
hello my name is Chad Bianco and I am
the sheriff of Riverside County
the reality is is when you smoke
marijuana whether you know there's
there's the false narrative out there
that um that it's not a gateway drug
that that people don't go in start using
other drugs that's absolutely false
um for the person that may be a
functional marijuana smoker more power
to you more power to you but the reality
of the criminal justice system is
everyone that's using math everyone
that's using heroin everyone that's
using fentanyl all of those kids all of
those young adults started with
marijuana
and then it led into something else they
didn't jump right in and say I think I
want to shoot heroin today it started
with marijuana
and I will tell you that over the last
couple of years and historically in the
the these shootings that we are involved
with where law enforcement is involved
with a suspect that is shooting at us or
we get involved in some type of
officer-involved shooting
almost all of them there may be one or
two exceptions but almost all of them
involve drug use and the majority of
that is a combination drug with you know
marijuana and something else marijuana
and alcohol marijuana methamphetamine
marijuana cocaine marijuana heroin
plain marijuana
those are the statistics that nobody
wants to hear nobody wants to talk about
and it's that segment of the population
it's not the it's not the you know the
the lawyer who smokes weed on the
weekends or goes home and you know
smokes a joint or or you know somebody
that's a casual smoker of marijuana and
has been for years and they're still
highly functional
they aren't criminals
they're not they they have a moral
ethical background that stops them from
victimizing people
that's not the population that law
enforcement deals with we don't deal
with them we don't we we never have
contact with them
we only deal with the people that are
committing crimes and those people are
heavily involved in drugs for the
majority
almost all crime can be traced back to
some type of a drug they were either
committed while on drugs or they were
committed for drugs all of our all or
most of our gang shootings are all
relating to drug trafficking the we even
have
um
human trafficking that's that's drug
related they're being trafficked for
drugs uh all you know robberies are
burglaries those are people stealing
those things to sell them for money to
use drugs
if the people that were making the laws
if the if our politicians if our
lawmakers if our if our city
Representatives would actually pay
attention to law enforcement and pay
attention to the experts that are
dealing with this on a day-to-day basis
we might be able to to turn it around
but instead law enforcement is demonized
law enforcement is blamed as the cause
of the problem not the criminal it's law
enforcement involved and our lawmakers
just refuse to have any type of dialogue
that has anything to do with fact or
statistics because the facts in the
statistics show
that were correct we're on the right
side of it law enforcement is and they
would have to change their agenda
it's causing a major increase in drug
use in in amongst our kids amongst our
adults it's causing an abuse problem and
then that leads into crime where we're
seeing more violent crime more crime in
general and it's a it's a spiral that
that we've got to start doing something
to stop